considera los polinomios p de x igual a
x a las seis menos x a las cinco menos x
al cubo - x cuadrada menos x y q de x
igual a x a la 4 - x al cubo - x
cuadrada menos 1 nos dicen si z1
sentados z3 y z4 son las raíces de q de
x esto es cuando q de x es igual a cero
calcula el polinomio p evaluado en z uno
más en z dos más pensé está 3 más pensé
está 4 muy bien entonces tenemos que
calcular esta suma así que si nos damos
pues bueno quizás primero sería bueno
empezar por escribir que q dz uno es lo
mismo que q dz dos y de hecho va a ser
igual a los otros dos verdad q dz 3 y
que también es q el z4 y esto va a ser
igual a 0 esto es porque se está a unos
160 3 y z4 son las raíces de q muy bien
justamente al evaluarlos en estos en
estos números esto nos debe dar
ok entonces ahora lo que podemos ver o
lo que deberíamos intentar es ver si
podemos escribir el polinomio p en
términos de q si podemos hacer esto al
menos ya sabemos que evaluado en q y
esto vale 0 vamos a ver si esto es
posible y fijémonos que q de x se parece
a p si lo multiplicamos por x cuadrada
tendríamos x cuadrada por x a la cuarta
es x a la 6 - x cuadrada por x al cubo
es menos x a la 5 y aquí ya fallaría un
poco pero si multiplicamos 1 x x
cuadrada nos da x cuadrada verdad
entonces se parecen vamos vamos a
escribirlo x cuadrada por q de x es
igual a x a la 6 - x cuadrada x x al
cubo es x a la 5 - x a la 4 - x cuadrada
muy bien entonces la pregunta es que
tengo que hacerle a esta expresión para
llegar a p de x si nos fijamos nos sobra
este x cuadrado entonces hay que sumarle
x cuadrada para quitarlo muy bien de
esta forma lo estaríamos quitando que
más nos falta menos x al cubo entonces
hay que restar menos x al cubo para que
aquí aparezca y además nos falta menos x
verdad entonces también le restamos x
para que aparezca entonces que es lo que
vamos a tener al final vamos a tener x
cuadrada por q de x y ahora sumamos
sumamos x 4a
- x cúbica menos x y esto debería ser
igual esto es igual a x a la 6 - x a la
5 éstos ya se cancelaron y nos queda
vámonos con este amarillo menos x al
cubo menos equis cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada menos x y justamente obtuvimos
pd x esto es exactamente igual
pd x entonces bueno quizás esta
expresión ya nos aproxima un poco porque
si te das cuenta q de x ya está aquí
expresado pero todavía no tenemos algo
muy claro que hacer pero si nos fijamos
ahora en esta parte de aquí esto se
empieza a aparecer acude x verdad
tenemos x a la cuarta menos x al cubo y
simplemente tenemos que restar x
cuadrada y menos 1 para tener q de x
verdad esto sería lo mismo que q de x
pero nos sobra x cuadrada bueno menos x
cuadrada y menos 1 así que si se lo
sumamos nos da esto que que marque con
el verde verdad entonces le sumamos x
cuadrada más 1 y que es lo que obtenemos
al final podremos reescribir pd x
pd x será igual a x cuadrada x cuadrada
q de x muy bien más esta parte que
subraya en verde que es q de x q de x
mas x cuadrada más 1 y nos falta restar
la x muy bien entonces al menos ya
podremos decir que está más simplificado
verdad o está escrito de mejor forma
porque sabemos que por ejemplo si para r
fue evaluado en heres se tiene que es 0
entonces quien sería evaluado en r y
recordemos que r va a tomar el papel de
z 1 z 273 o de z 4 entonces quién sería
pdr si suponemos que q se anula con esa
r entonces pdr sería r cuadrada werner
nr más ere cuadrada menos
r sería éste más 1 muy bien sin embargo
como se anulan este término de aquí ya
no pinta y éste tampoco ok esos dos se
desaparecen ahora esto simplemente nos
quedó entonces r cuadrada menos ser más
1 muy bien y es una expresión muy muy
muy sencillita vamos a vamos a irlo
aterrizando en lo que nosotros tenemos
tendremos
que como cuenta aún no se anula pz 1
sería igual a esto que obtuvimos z 1 al
cuadrado menos aquí es menos menos z 1
más 1 op ahora vamos a tener lo mismo
para z 2 vamos a ponerlo con otro color
p en z 2 será igual a z 2 al cuadrado
menos z 2 más 1 también vamos a tener lo
mismo para t evaluado en z 3
esto será z 3 al cuadrado menos z 3 más
1 y finalmente también lo tendremos para
p en z 4 en z 4 será z 4 al cuadrado
menos z 4 más 1 entonces la pregunta
ahora la pregunta ahora es si con esta
información ya podemos obtener la suma
que queremos verdad y si nos damos
cuenta aquí ya podemos sumar digamos
esto es lo que lo que nos daría la suma
sería lo mismo que sumar lo que está de
este lado derecho sin embargo bueno uno
tú dirás oye ésta está muy padre que tú
quieras sumar sin embargo no sé qué es
esta suma verdad no sabemos en principio
que es la suma de pse está a unos
estados z 364 cuando están elevados al
cuadrado sin embargo lo vimos ya justo
en vídeos anteriores y es que este tema
de la suma de las raíces de un polinomio
y demás no es algo que se que se vea en
los cursos clásicos de álgebra esto ya
es un tema un poco más avanzado y que lo
hace la gente que se dedica a estudiar
propiedades divertidas de los polinomios
y justamente vimos cómo se calcula la
suma de de las raíces de un polinomio y
la suma de los cuadrados de las raíces
de un polinomio entonces eso esos vídeos
ya los puse en la lista de las
competencias de matemáticas y también en
las de álgebra muy bien entonces en
principio si uno suma estos unos pues
nos debe dar cuatro muy bien ahora bien
qué pasa si yo sumo
de aquí qué pasa si yo sumo estos de acá
en realidad voy a tener menos z 1 maceta
273 maceta 4 muy bien y esto es menos la
suma de todos o bueno menos la suma de
las raíces de q y eso ya sabíamos verdad
esto debe ser igual al negativo del
segundo término de orden más alto verdad
bueno más bien sería el siguiente del
orden más alto en este caso en este caso
tenemos aquí que x a la cuarta es el
orden más alto entonces menos uno menos
uno es el coeficiente del siguiente
término entonces será el negativo esto
de aquí esto de aquí será el negativo de
ese coeficiente que es menos 1 y esto es
1 pero como tenemos este menos de aquí
simplemente nos vuelve a dar menos 1
entonces esta suma esta suma por debido
a los vídeos que ya vimos
-1 ahora la siguiente pregunta es quién
es o cuánto vale la suma de los
cuadrados de las raíces de q entonces
tenemos z 1 al cuadrado más z 2 al
cuadrado más z 3 al cuadrado más z 4 al
cuadrado muy bien y esto cuánto vale
bueno esto quedamos en aquellos vídeos
que es menos 1 es el término es decir el
término que sigue al más alto el
coeficiente y eso elevado al cuadrado
entonces sería menos 1 al cuadrado menos
2 por el siguiente coeficiente que
digamos que le sigue al segundo más alto
entonces sería este que aquí son menos 1
o lo que es lo mismo el coeficiente de
22 grados abajo del más grande verdad
entonces aquí sería menos 2 x menos 1
y esto sería 1 verdad menos uno al
cuadrado es 1 y menos 2 x menos 1 es
2 entonces esto nos queda simplemente 3
así que esta suma de aquí nos da 3 y ya
hemos terminado porque ya podemos
calcular esta suma muy sencilla que nos
dice tres menos uno son dos más cuatro
nos da seis y el vídeo queda concluido
con con el resultado que es 6